bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
la prochaine formation gouvernementale
libyenne oui on pense toujours c'est la
solution magique enfin va voir un
gouvernement d'union nationale mais
magie toujours pessimistes vis-à-vis de
la crise libyenne pour un simple raison
parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
politiques et on oublie les militaires
est ce que c'est le politique qui prime
sur les militaires ou celle averses
n'ont jusqu'à maintenant ce sont les
militaires qui ont le grand mort ce sont
les militaires qui maîtrisent la
situation
la libye divisée en deux des cirques
vers djofra est liée à l'armée nationale
dirigé par le match entre alès et
plusieurs milices à l'ouest à leur tête
le conseil militaire de misrata roue de
zenten donc plusieurs protagonistes ont
les armes dès lors qu'ils sont enrichis
grâce à cette guerre depuis plus que
disons alors est ce que les militaires
vont obéir facilement sans objection à
ces politiques j'ai des forts doutes et
l'expérience l'a bien montré
et malgré tout il ya bien cette équipe
gouvernementale constituée par le
premier ministre libyen on sait
finalement peu de choses
aucun nom n'a été donnée quel enjeu est
ce qu'il avait est-ce qu'il a en tête
pour que le prochain gouvernement fois
validé par le parlement
or il faut il faut satisfaire l'est et
l'ouest et le sud à la fois il faut
satisfaire les parlements de tobrouk et
le parlement du tripoli je parle de deux
parlements parce qu'en juin 2014
il y a eu des élections législatives en
libye la partie cela mist qui dominait
très polis n'ont pas accepté les
résultats parce qu'ils ont perdu ces
élections donc le hall à l éclatement de
parlement on a le parlement tripoli un
autre à table donc si ce gouvernement
arrive à initier tous les députés de ces
deux parlements ce sera extraordinaire
il doit satisfaire tout le monde y
compris les militaires qui détiennent le
vrai pouvoir
la tâche est très très difficile la
tâche et hardy la solution électorale ce
toujours la solution américains comme
l'ont fait en irak après 2003 faire des
élections et voilà ça c'est la
démocratie en or la démocratie c'est
autre chose c'est tout d'abord une
culture une pratique c'est tout un
ensemble mais jusqu'à maintenant on a
négligé la libye on a négligé les tribus
libyennes laiterie les tribus les biens
sont des acteurs plus fort plus
puissante que les partis politiques et
la société libyenne est une société
tribale
on n'a pas pris ça en considération
malheureusement je pense et c'est
toujours ce sont ces solutions
politiques préparer en occitan à genève
ou à new york wall l'onu avec des hauts
fonctionnaires et sans le savoir la
vraie réalité sociologique de la société
libyenne être il ya donc une stratégie
alors dans la décision du premier
ministre est bien de ne révéler les noms
des membres choisis pour participer à
l'équipe gouvernementale uniquement
devant le parlement dans quelques jours
parce qu'il veut gagner du temps il veut
gagner le maximum de soutien le gagner
le maximum de soutien s'il arrive à
convaincre 90 % que dans la vie pour son
délit bien aux défenses politique
libyenne et s'il arrive à convaincre les
tribus ça sera un pas excellent en avant
mais le grand problème reste pour lui
évidemment un problème d'ordre
structurel c'est pas un problème
politique
c'est que l'état n'a pas le monopole de
la violence légitime comme le disait max
weber
ça veut dire n'y a pas une armée
nationale unique
il n'y a pas et police nationale unique
comment elle va crise est un mets
national qui doit sécuriser le pays de
l'est à l'ouest et du nord au sud
ça c'est une trash tâche quasi
impossible elle est très très difficile
mais espérons qu'elle arrive à
l'accomplir la vie de bébé a été désigné
à la surprise générale premier ministre
le 5 février dernier par 75 délégué
libyen de tout bon ils étaient réunis
à genève sous l'égide de l'onu quel a
été son action depuis quel regard est ce
que vous portez bon pour moi ce qui
s'est passé à genève
c'est pas une démocratie on a parlé des
élections alors on n'a jamais dit qui a
élu les 75 10 les délégués qui sont
actionnaires afin d'élire j'ai souhaité
qu'ils appliquent la tuerie de consensus
est une ressource politique ça veut dire
pas d'élections en angoua trouver un
gouvernement un conseil présidentiel par
consensus papa élections parce que si on
fait des élections tout soixante quinze
délégués la grande question que s'est
posée qui a élu les soixante quinze
délégués avant de représenter le peuple
libyen
c'est pour cela je suis pas très
optimiste pour la crise libyenne parce
que c'est pas la première fois que les
libyens se réunissent à serait apte au
maroc en algérie et en egypte à berlin
en allemagne en france en italie à
mouscou partout dans le monde les
libyens sont réunis mais finalement les
militaires et les forces armées ne
respectent pas leur accord dont la libye
reste dans le statut chaos
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse riadh
sidaoui je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du centre arabe de recherche
et d analyse la politique à genève